saludos en el vídeo anterior
mencionábamos que si tenemos dos
vectores a va a ser uno de nuestros
vectores y va a ser igual a menos tres y
recordamos nuestra anotación de vectores
unitarios más dos j y voy a tener otro
vector que voy a llamar de y es igual a
dos y
+ 4 j
recordemos que y j son vectores
unitarios y está en el eje xy j está en
el eje y y en el vídeo anterior
mencionábamos que una de las cosas
interesantes sobre este tipo de notación
es que nos permite hacer la suma o la
operación de vectores mucho más sencilla
antes de tener esta anotación lo que
teníamos que hacer para sumar vectores
era dibujar los dibujar el primer vector
y luego dibujar el segundo vector con
origen en la punta del vector anterior y
luego unir el origen del primero con la
punta del último para tener la suma de
vectores y no teníamos otra forma de
expresar lo más que dibujando lo y ahora
que tenemos los vectores expresados en
múltiplos de los vectores unitarios ya
no tenemos que dibujar los y se vuelve
muy sencillo sumar vectores y cómo lo
hacemos simplemente sumamos los
componentes de ahí y sumamos los
componentes de j
así que nuestra suma de los vectores a
recuerden que esta flechita de encima
indica que son vectores más el vector
va a ser igual menos tres más dos
los componentes de j
2 más
4 j
aquí estamos sumando los múltiplos de i
y aquí estamos sumando los múltiplos de
j así que la suma de estos dos vectores
va a ser igual a menos tres más dos
menos uno
que podría poner menos sí pero lo voy a
dejar aquí explícito porque estamos
familiarizándonos con esta anotación más
la suma de los componentes en j 2 + 4 es
igual a 6 6 por jota y bueno ya que
hicimos esto ustedes me pueden decir
bueno yo no puedo confiar ciegamente en
lo que me dices de que esta es la suma
de estos dos rectores tengo que
comprobar y hacen bien siempre hay que
tener pensamiento crítico nunca crear
las cosas ciegamente y para demostrarles
que esto es la suma de estos dos
vectores vamos a dibujarlos y hacer la
suma visualmente vamos a dibujar los
ejes aquí está un eje
aquí está el otro eje les pongo las
flechas para indicar que estos ejes
continúan más allá de donde los podemos
ver
este es x este es ya vamos a hacer las
graduaciones 1 2
4 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 vamos
a dibujar el vector a el componente en x
del vector a este de aquí menos 3 y es
un vector que se va a ver así
123 menos 3 aquí está va hacia la
izquierda porque y este vector va hacia
la derecha pero este va en sentido
contrario por eso lo dibujamos hacia acá
y esta parte del vector 2 j es la que
corresponde al eje vertical y este va de
esta manera + 2 j
aquí está y este es mi vector ha
expresado mediante sus componentes
vertical y horizontal y si quisiéramos
sumar estos vectores podríamos desplazar
este vector hacia arriba o este vector
hacia la izquierda de manera que uno de
estos dos vectores comience en lo
determina el otro vector y creo que
ahorita nos convendría desplazar este
toda esta distancia hasta acá
entonces este vector menos 2 j lo estoy
desplazando aquí estos vectores son
iguales lo único que cambio es en donde
los puse pero tiene la misma dirección y
la misma magnitud y voy a hacer un color
un poquito distinto para dibujar este
vector a con el método de suma de
vectores de colocar el inicio de un
vector en la punta del otro nos queda
que este vector a al sumar sus
componentes va a hacer este vector este
es mi vector aquí hicimos las cosas al
contrario de como lo veníamos haciendo
aquí les di el componente vertical
el componente horizontal y el componente
vertical y después lo que hicimos fue
hacer la suma para encontrar el vector
original este es mi vector a y aquí en
lugar de hacer el dibujo simplemente
tengo la forma analítica de este vector
y ahora dibujemos de la misma manera el
vector
vemos su componente horizontal 2 y vamos
desde el origen sobre el eje 12 aquí
está este es el componente horizontal de
mi vector b 2
y ahora dibujemos su componente vertical
4 j desde el origen sobre el eje de las
es 1 2 3 4 de magnitud
y aquí está este otro componente de b y
ahora desplazamos este vector que acabo
de dibujar en la punta de este vector
así de manera que va en la misma
dirección tiene la misma magnitud es
decir es el mismo vector solo que está
desplazado acá y ahora que tengo este
vector comenzando desde la punta de este
otro vector puedo hacer la suma de
vectores así que mi vector b va a quedar
así 1 el origen de este vector con la
punta de este otro vector hasta aquí y
este es mi vector b visto gráficamente y
si yo quisiera sumar estos dos vectores
de manera visual haría lo mismo que hice
con estos otros tendría que desplazar
algunos de estos elementos de manera que
el origen de un vector esté en la punta
del otro vector y
la cual vamos a desplazar yo creo que
vamos a desplazar este vector
hacia la punta del vector b
recuerden que mientras mantengamos la
magnitud y la dirección de un vector no
importa en dónde lo dibujemos el vector
va a ser el mismo así que este vector
que estoy dibujando aquí sigue siendo el
vector a solo que está desplazado aquí
este es mi vector a y ahora si puedo
hacer la suma ya que tengo este vector b
y en la punta del vector b estoy
dibujando el origen del vector a así que
la suma de este vector b con el vector
es este vector que resulta al unir el
inicio de b con el fin de a aquí está
este es mi vector suma de estos dos y
así es como resulta haciéndolo
gráficamente ahora veamos si este vector
que acabo de dibujar es este vector que
representa aquí así que esta parte de
aquí este menos 1 y
es este vector desde el origen menos uno
sobre el eje de las equis aquí está
menos uno
y este otro elemento este otros vectores
6 j del origen hacia arriba 1 2 3 4 5 6
bueno me quedo un poco fuera de el
dibujo de mi eje pero quedaría aquí 6 j
sobre el eje de las íes con una magnitud
de 6 y la dirección hacia arriba ahora
si yo sumo estos dos vectores obtendré
este vector verde claro vamos a
desplazar este vector de acá el que
dibujamos sobre el eje de las jotas aquí
y voy a desplazarlo para eso lo dibujo
aquí donde termina mi vector en el eje
de las 10 aquí está este vector
desplazado aquí arriba y ahora sí puedo
sumar este vector que estoy remarcando
aquí para que se note el 6 j
en el -1 y como podemos ver la suma de
estos dos vectores nos dio este mismo
vector verde resultado de la suma de
vectores gráfica y es el mismo que nos
dio nuestra suma analítica y creo que
esto puede ser un poco confuso sobre
todo con todos los colores que estuve
usando pero el punto aquí es aunque
ustedes pueden hacer esa suma de
vectores gráfico dibujando cada vector y
luego desplazando un vector para poner
su origen en la punta del otro y unirlos
ambos para encontrar la suma pero ahora
también tienen esta otra forma analítica
de representar lo que de hecho para
hacer la suma es mucho más sencillo
mucho más directo que estar haciendo
todos estos dibujos además tenemos la
limitante de que estos dibujos solo los
podemos hacer en dos dimensiones ya para
dibujar vectores en más dimensiones esto
ya se complica demasiado en cambio aquí
solamente sumamos los elementos de cada
uno de los ejes y tenemos el resultado
mucho más fácil mucho más limpio y con
menos probabilidad de error
espero que con esto les haya convencido
de que la suma de ve realizada de este
modo analítico nos da el mismo resultado
que hacer la suma de esos vectores de
manera gráfica y ahora que espero los
haya convencido de que esta anotación de
vectores es muy útil vamos a proceder a
hacer algunos de los problemas de
movimiento de proyectiles que ya
habíamos hecho con anterioridad pero
usando esta nueva anotación y quizás
hacer cosas un poquito más complicadas
más adelante nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo